Facebook's proposals create its own
digital currency called Libre has gotten
a lot of backlash from global regulators
Facebook has burned down the house over
and over it's been the subject of acidic
u.s. congressional hearings and Frances
finance minister went so far as to say
that it was an assault on national
sovereignty do officials in other
countries including China Germany and
Italy have expressed similar concerns
here's what regulators are worried about
for one lawmakers worried that Libre has
the potential to disrupt the monetary
system if Libre becomes the currency for
Facebook's 2.4 billion or so users to
say nothing of other companies that
might accept it it could become a
globally significant currency how Libre
is going to be what's called in crypto
markets a stable coin it will be a
pegged currency that maintains basically
a 1 to 1 value with the US dollar that's
a different model than Bitcoin Bitcoin
trades freely and its value is
determined solely upon what people are
willing to pay for it to maintain that
peg the group that it will be governing
this currency called the Libre
Association will maintain a reserve for
every dollars worth of Libre that is
created one dollar is going to be put
into the reserve theoretically that
means that this reserve could hold
billions or even trillions of dollars
worth of currencies and short term
securities that is a very powerful tool
in capital markets if that money got
moved around significantly from one
currency to another it could absolutely
upset global markets now that's not to
say that Facebook or the Liebherr
Association is expected to do something
like weaponize these reserves however
this is the first time that not a
government but a private company or a
group of private companies would have
that kind of power Facebook and the
Liebherr association of companies
backing the project say they are
committed to working with authorities to
achieve a safe transparent and
consumer-friendly implementation of the
digital currency lawmakers who are
already looking into Facebook for a
number of other reasons are not
comfortable with Facebook's power the
tech company is battling scrutiny on
multiple fronts from its role in
elections to privacy to even antitrust
investigation
Facebook is dangerous they don't respect
the power of the technologies Facebook's
business model it's rolling spreading
propaganda and its controversial efforts
to rein it in have infuriated lawmakers
we will have to make very strong
commitments so that people trust us and
we will have to honor those commitments
for a very long period of time to earn
people's trust at the core of a lot of
the distrust among governments is that
Facebook has been criticized for its
handling of user data before and Libra
would create a traceable record of all
its users transactions just imagine a
company being able to combine your
identity your online habits and your
spending patterns that is an
unprecedented ocean of data at this
summer's congressional hearings Facebook
executive David Marcus said the company
and the Liebherr Association will keep
the spending data separate from the user
identities lawmakers course were
skeptical of that I have serious
concerns with Facebook's plans
regulators scrutiny is one of the
reasons libras viability has been called
into question and some key companies
that initially back the project have
ducked out with Visa saying its decision
to work with the project in the future
depends on libras ability to satisfy
regulatory expectations we'll have to
wait and see whether this scrutiny from
regulators makes Leever stronger or ends
up threatening its existence altogether